[Music]
you look great man did you do something
different uh yeah i'm on a new diet
oh no way
just eating fruits and vegetables now i
feel amazing i don't miss the other
foods at all wow that's great so i guess
you don't want that pizza that's
backstage
left
jokes on taric because i ate it
you guys it's been a crazy week in a
minute
anyway yeah and nothing
not even crust no here you can i have a
mint under my desk
i mean it's better than nothing it's
better than nothing you guys it's been a
crazy week in america let's find out
what happened
president biden visited queens this week
he's the second most important head of
state to go there
while surveying hurricane damage this
week president biden said that climate
change and extreme weather are a quote
code red said americans you had us at
code red
i love to act like i'm too good for it
but i
will
chug a friggin do
i'll give a rip look i'm from omaha
nebraska i i know mountain don't for me
i can't do it what
mountain don't mountain won't oh man i'm
cancer
mountain dope mountain won't mountain
camp
cosmetic filler injections will become
illegal in britain next month for people
under 18 which is sad because if there's
one thing british people need it's lips
let them have it dang
in other british news due to the
pandemic buckingham palace recently
conducted their first changing of the
guard ceremony in 18 months which makes
me think maybe it's finally safe for us
to do the same thing so please enjoy the
amber ruffin show's very first changing
of the security guard
hope you can go on break now jim thanks
jim anytime jen
what a thrill yeah
according to a new study climate change
may have caused the physical features of
some animals to evolve for example deer
used to look like this
and now they look like this
[Laughter]
you guys you guys at home can't see this
but i told that joke and none of the
audience left so
a 24 million dollar pink diamond
embedded in the forehead of rapper lil
uzi vert was reportedly ripped out this
summer while he crowdsurfed at a music
festival
and police have released a drawing of
the suspect
[Applause]
it was thanos it was thanos he's the
soul stone and he's he all he only needs
like two more stones he only needs two
more stones and then friggin dead dude
we're dead we're dead but he will look
fantastic it looks so good yeah it would
be worth it we'll turn the powder and go
oh he looks so good
hulu has announced that in october the
price of subscriptions that include ads
will increase to seven dollars a month
which is bad news for whoever's hulu
account i'm using
moms i don't know it's mine oh sorry t
that's all right and
finally due to the coronavirus the cdc
this week added jamaica to its list of
very high risk travel locations
that's not going to stop us from going
said white people with dreadlocks
and that was a monologue did you guys
like it
okay
i'm glad you like that monologue because
it's all downhill from here yeah now
we've covered some of this week's big
news but we haven't talked about one of
the biggest stories yet
texas's new abortion law the law that
went into effect on september 1st and
it it makes abortion illegal in the
state after six weeks
opponents to the bill have protested
using the phrase my body my choice but
was it ever
let's take a look at a woman's body
now
what we have here on this easel is a
woman's body so let's start at the top
and then see what parts exactly are your
choice okay let's see your hair
well you can't always have dreadlocks at
your school or workplace sometimes black
people get fired if someone at work
doesn't like how they wear their hair i
know one time i did
not from that sandwich place but the
other sandwich place so
that's gonna be a no
no you're not in charge of your own hair
that's a no
no sorry everybody
and a little lower we find a woman's
mouth now if you're a woman no one wants
to hear you say your opinion also 27
states have introduced bills prohibiting
teachers from talking about critical
race theory in their classroom and guess
what 76 percent of teachers in america
are women so if you want to talk openly
and honestly about the history of racism
too freaking bad plus many companies
have rules against talking to your
co-workers about how much you make rules
that are specifically designed to make
sure women don't find out they're making
less than men so you can't talk about
racism and you can't talk about your
salary also if you talk like this where
your sentences go up at the end people
freak them out so sorry
it is not your mouth your choice now a
little bit lower you can find the torso
now what you put on your torso is your
choice right
wrong most schools dress codes are
targeted specifically at girls telling
them what they can and can't wear so
sorry that torso is not your choice and
your uterus belongs to the lord so
there's no choice there
instead of an x i'm just gonna put a
little cross
which brings us to your butt
your butt
sweetie i run that ass no i'm just
kidding
i'm like that must tell you
the butt is all yours go nuts now your
knees well you better not take one or
else you'll be in big trouble these are
not your choice your feet well not if
you work at a job that requires you to
wear high heels
freaking gross and that's about it we
have a lot fewer choices than we thought
this abortion ban stinks it's gonna put
a lot of people in real danger i'm sorry
about it i hate it these people are
organized and powerful but they're also
the minority we are the majority so
let's start acting like it we're
finished yet find an organization near
you that's fighting to help women
control their bodies and donate your
time or money to them let's stay in this
together so women have fun with your uh
your butts i mean fart it up i don't
know my butt my choice
say it with me my butt my choice
just
one more butt circle
now there's one other big story i'd like
to talk about tonight the fda recently
approved pfizer's coven 19 vaccine which
is freaking great news now a lot of
people felt skeptical because the
emergency rollout didn't give enough
time to thoroughly vet it well now they
have and you can relax knowing that
there is no poison
in the vaccine
isn't that right james it sure is amber
no
poison in fact we have a song for all
those who may still be on the fence
about getting vaccinated
[Applause]
fights are vaccine in full effect are
you ready james i'm ready you ready
amber yeah i'm ready america are you
ricky
girl i must warn you
i sense that you're causing lots of harm
situation is serious
let's cure it with two shots in the arm
it's also ridiculous
conspiracy to receive from the start
it's all so deadly
they believe it because they aren't very
smart
check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
information now some of them did there
is no poison
[Applause]
fda approved
[Music]
if i were you i take precaution
before i get my news from facebook
information is out there
from qualified medical professionals
take a look
[Music]
they're so smart
they have medical
expertise you think you know better
[ __ ] please don't be excluded for
thinking something stupid
you'll be dying all alone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're picking out a casket cause you
wouldn't ask it see what i'm saying huh
stuck in the house i know your life's
hard
how do you know no vaccination card
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fda approved this time there is no
poison
[Applause]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
[Music]